[Music]
Glory be to God. There is no doubt that it gives a person motivation,
even for the next new life. If he returns to his family, it
gives him motivation from humanity, and from here the charging of energies
and inspiration
in these wondrous sights, and
this is from the grace of God Almighty.
[Music]
I am leaving Qatar, the northern lands, north of
Saudi Arabia, because of this.  The atmosphere that is beautiful means,
God willing, God bless you. It means inspired by
imagination. The atmosphere means creative, praise be to God. The scenery means
beautiful, it
takes the soul back. It means it is as if you are going crazy. It means we hear a description of heaven. It means it is as if you are,
God willing, God bless you. It is considered the same drawing
and it is worth all this distance.
[Music]